I who created everything so we're
talking about I don't know I mean dead
ass we can never really know for sure
who created everything could be a god it
could be like just nature it from the
top yeah I was just looking at um which
which one I know there is a burdens will
bear the burden of another okay good all
[Music]
right the main goal of a mentor is to
pass on the energy of a
[Music]
win those chosen by a mentor have the
capability to harness this energy Gilla
power for your greatest fight talking
about atheism how could you be an
atheist you look very smart to not be an
atheist like for example your ring you
have a ring well you know what's that
look for for example what you're wearing
right now has a pattern correct it has a
purpose you wore it today to it maybe it
looks nice or whatever for the mess I
always wear my best okay good so it has
it has it sentimental as well so we say
the following my sister are you more
complex in design from your eyes to your
teeth from your heart to your lungs to
your legs to your arms or
that well obviously you yeah so the
question I need to ask is the following
if that has a purpose if that has a
design it has a
designer you have no design you have a
designer who created you that's my
question good but who created your mom
and who created everything so we're
talking about I don't know I mean there
us we can never really know for who
created everything could be a it could
be like just nature know it could be
anything you know what's your name
Sister Sarah Sarah my name is Ali so let
me explain something sister when we talk
about nature nature is a blind process
science okay okay science tells us how
things work it doesn't tell us why they
work the way you do yeah so I have no
problem with science are you science in
my life it helps me there's so many
things we're not against science what
we're saying is the following Evolution
not Evolution when need talk about
nature nature is a blind process when
you look at yourself your eyes are in a
imagine if your eyes were on your toes I
mean life will be very difficult yeah
okay so imagine your teeth are in the
right place for you to True your saliva
has a purpose your teeth have a purpose
your digestive system have a purpose
when you cut yourself for example I had
a cut you a long time ago I don't know
if you can see it but it it it it healed
itself who is telling my white s or the
things in my body to say oh my gosh he's
bleeding Let's help him where did this
information come from sorry the brain no
no the brain but before the brain there
are things the white cells and the blood
cells and that we have that have their
own way of going about things and doing
things like for example your kidney do
you tell your kidney to cleanse the
water that you drink what tells it so
what we're seeing is the one that
created you had to will that there is
order and process otherwise this nature
that we're talking about it's blind
process how could it give rise to order
you get what I'm trying to say your
eyebrows have a purpose your eyelashes
have a purpose
you get what I'm trying to say and for
example why doesn't our eyelashes grow
so much like maybe long as my beard I
get that you know but even if there is a
you never really done me good okay good
so this is what we talk about look I've
been from stuff in my life before I came
to Islam and in Islam actually I got
really tested a lot when I became a
Muslim but Allah tells us in the Quran
my dear sister this life is not for us
to just have Jo just peace and pky Dory
of course there is that for example
you're standing here today as a healthy
girl you can drink yeah do you do you
feel pain when you eat no good so can
you imagine how merciful god is that
when we eat food we enjoy it yeah we
don't feel imagine we have to feel pain
every time we ate and it was like
painful now what I'm saying is that does
that mean we're not going to be tested a
Muslim gets cancer a non-muslim gets
cancer a Muslim gets in a car crash a
non-muslim so the point is the following
though my sister when you have a
connection with God Almighty everything
falls into place like this verse here
that we for only in the remembrance of
God do hearts find peace this is a verse
in the Quran which means the following
my sister that the way God has created
me and you we will only find happiness
and contentment in his remembrance look
I used to go clubbing I used to go
partying I used to do all this stuff in
my life before I came to Islam I hit a
brick wall cuz it was not enough I
always wanted more no matter what I got
the latest car the latest what we to
call it girlfriend whatever always want
more which means that the soul is
actually craving something that is
beyond this life which is God Almighty
so the Quran what it does is sister is
helps you to build that relationship
with God Almighty and gives you a
purpose in life for example you already
have a religion you're an atheist yeah
you say to me I don't have a religion
right but I believe you do why for
example can you what kind of food can
you not
eat nothing I mean I eat see that's your
religion so in your religion you can
have any food in my religion I can't
have pork in your religion can you drink
alcohol
I don't know I didn't really like but in
your way of life like would you have you
drunk alcohol before yeah okay good so
you see you have a way of life I also
have a way of life yeah we all are bound
to follow a way of life the only
difference is this my sister we believe
that the Quran is from God Mighty it
tells you to live a life yeah but but
it's not just for me look it changed my
life for the better it give me purpose I
know why I'm here imagine your you woke
up on a train and you've got everything
you could ever wish for on the train but
there's one question You' ask yourself
who put me here and where the hell am I
going correct I you know I think that
you know but I
just I don't know you know what that is
sister that's basically I was where you
was like I was an atheist I was a theist
but I was where you was about 13 14
years ago so why am I here I'll be
honest like I would look at like things
like my watch and I'll be like these all
have a purpose what's my purpose like
are you kidding me are you telling me my
socks have a purpose and I just randomly
popped in here and have no purpose so
you as a human being you have a greater
purpose purp and that is to have that
relationship with God Almighty and then
the trials and tests you went through
everything will make sense because we
have the pixel God has the picture there
are certain things we go in life that we
don't understand obviously look I don't
want to give you a sermon I know I'm
talking too much
but like like yeah yeah look I genuinely
believe find it I believe you look you
look sincere you're like you listening
Etc and I believe there's goodness in
new sister you know and you want nothing
to lose like I mean it's a free copy we
can give you a free copy can I GI to you
one yes sure so like we can gift it
and and you can read it and what I did
um 13 years ago sisters before I opened
any Scripture I put them all in front of
me and I said God whichever is the true
path guide me to it make that sincere
prayer ask God just say look God I went
through difficulty in my life I'm
searching I don't know why I'm here I
don't know what's going on but I want
you to guide me whatever it is you know
and you can look if you want even you
can do it now you can open a random
verse of the
Quran just point out to any like
is any specific
R any number that you want me to
read which one is your eyes
on I'm looking at this one okay what is
that let me see what chapter is
it let me just see what
chapter it's Sur
which verse should I read it from the
top yeah I was just looking at um which
which one I know a or bear the bur of
another okay good all right so this is f
let me open on my phone is it verse is
18 uh yeah okay right let me open it so
I can read it
properly right what you guys up to today
I'm just walking around just is it oh
that's good you know I used to you know
this very place I used to go like Lally
clubing here every week oh is it yeah
yeah and I'm being honest like I just
thought that was life but I'll be honest
with you when you have God in your life
I promise you and I hope one day you
taste this no music no alcohol none of
this like when you have this contentment
and this relationship with God you know
why you're here you know when you know
why you're here and where you're going
like life is so clear up you know what
you're expecting from life you know why
you're here you know what the objective
is and life makes so much sense but when
you are looking for happiness and I did
that like when I was like going through
depression or this that and I let me
just go to the clubs let me just go
holiday but it was never enough I would
go I'll just get bored you go holiday
you get bored it's just everything comes
to an end the reason why it's like that
is because God has programmed it that
you only find happiness in him so it's
like we get hungry and we eat food so we
can survive but firstly we drink water
but your soul also needs nourishment so
your soul is calling out for the God's
remembrance and then anytime you're like
okay you know what there's something
missing I know clubing boyfriend this or
that or car and it's like no that void
is God Almighty but um let's read that
verse so Allah says in the Quran the one
you just picked and no burdens and no
burden Soul can bear the burden of
another person and if a heavily loaded
person calls another for help is
carrying its own load so this is talking
about the day of judgment we will all
have our Deeds weighed I will not be
carrying your Deeds you will not be
carrying
mine nothing of it will be lifted even
if he was a near relative which is even
if it's your mom or your dad everybody's
going to be judged equally you can warn
only those who fear the R means Lord so
my job is like me talking to you here is
just conveying the message I can't
change your heart I can just say look
there's a day of judgment coming
interest you I'm actually like
yeah yeah so it says the Rob the Rob on
the Unseen and established prayer so
praying and believing in the Unseen so
believe in the Angels believe in the
scriptures Etc he who purifies himself
gets purified only to his own benefit so
the one who wants guidance will only do
it for your own benefit like what that
means is very important cuz a lot of
people come and say why does God need me
to pray God doesn't need nothing from us
if every single human being stop praying
God doesn't need us we rather need God
so the what Allah saying in the Quran is
that the one who purifies himself and
gets closer to God you're only doing it
for your own self because you're going
to benefit in Paradise we believe in
Hellfire and Paradise we believe in
Paradise no ear has heard no eye has
seen no nose or mouth has tasted
anything you want is is there for you
the only thing God is asking is have
that relationship with him and try to
forgo the sins and temptations of this
life purified his own self for his own
benefit and to Allah is the end Journey
meaning our end Journey when we die is
going to be in front of God Almighty
I'll read the next verse let me know
when you need to go I don't want to hold
you uh yeah okay yeah let me know
whenever you I don't I don't want to
give a sermon sister yeah so not equal
are the Blind and the one that seen so
when we're talking about blind and sight
we sometimes think about eyes Allah
talks about the hearts it says it's not
the eyes that are blind but it's the
hearts because there are people who like
you have scientist you talked about they
go and study like quantums they study
the snowflake you know the snowflake
have you seen the pattern yeah and they
say oh this was by chance I mean how
could you look at that study the human
mind study this human eye the kidney and
the heart and say oh this is just a
random really the heart the way it
functions and be it's random so Allah is
saying the one that's blind and the one
that's sing is not the same you'll agree
to that
right and nor are the darkness and the
light meaning Darkness and Light are two
opposites correct so Allah's
distinguishing between those who are on
the right path and those who are not and
I'll read the last verse and nor equal
are the shade and the Heat of the Sun
and not equal are the living and the
dead so just Allah's given comparison
blind seen dark um light um you know so
Allah's given this contrast to show us
sister that guidance is light when
you're in darkness when there's a peep
of light light you appreciate that
you're like oh my gosh amongst this
Darkness that's where I believe I was
back in before I came to Islam I was in
darkness and you know in darkness you
bump your head you don't know where
you're going but when God gives you that
light things are more clear so to me my
dear sister to you is Sarah yeah yeah so
I'm bad with name I'm I remembered yeah
my name is Ali so I would say sister is
read the Quran pray to God can I give
you a free prayer mat okay so I'll tell
you how this works here so it's a it's
free it's from our charity um let me
show you what it looks like this is free
from us uh sheam can you give me the uh
the prayer map so I can show the sister
no no no the the open
one open one open one yeah thank you so
sister so what I've given you it's looks
like
this so I would say personally this
shows us like this how we Muslims pray
so he's praying sitting down because
he's got his legs I'm going to go pray
now as well so what you've got in there
is this if you ever in a difficulty if
you ever feel like there's no way out
just turn to God Almighty and just say
look however you like like I mean you
know you can follow this or however you
like sit down and just pray to him and
say look I'm looking for guidance guide
me and I promise you and I know you're
sincere if you genuinely and sincerely
sincerely ask that you will see things
change in your life you will see signs
and I even believe you coming here today
is not coincidence so yeah that's what
I'll say s if you have any questions uh
that's it other than that thank you for
your time thanks for listening I know I
talk a lot my my wife says that I talk a
lot as well
if I'm like something I can don't worry
and we're here to listen thank you
sister and hopefully enj we don't shake
hands out respect it's like the queen
you know the queen nobody can shake the
Queen's hand right so to us every woman
as a queen so so and the same with my
wifei just so you know as Muslim men I
I'm not allowed to shake the hand of a
Muslim woman I'm sorry no no no don't no
I'm not offended I'm just letting you
know that you don't feel offended so
it's the same with a Muslim woman as
well thank you sister thank you take
care and you can watch my videos Ali da
thank you sister thank you may Allah
guide her she was a really nice sister
and make Dua for